m giraron la ruleta para ganar un premio
m que obtuvo el número 17 y tom obtuvo
un número que supera por 15 al de mk así
es que qué número obtuvo tom tú ponle
una pausa del vídeo e intenta
descubrirlo por tu cuenta a mí lo que me
gusta hacer en estos ejercicios es
escribir todo lo que me dicen y
entenderlo muy bien aunque por aquí nos
dicen que emeka obtuvo el número 17
aunque yo entonces voy a escribir por
aquí que emeka obtuvo el número 17
aunque hay de hecho lo tenemos por aquí
ok esto es lo que obtuvo mk bueno y
ahora qué pasa con tom
puesto obtuvo un número que supera por
15 al de mk y esto lo que quiere decir
es que el número que obtuvo tom tiene 15
unidades más
que el número que obtuvo m k
así es que quien obtuvo un número más
grande
mk o tom bueno pues el número que obtuvo
tom tiene 15 unidades más que el de mk
así es que va a ser un número más grande
de hecho va a ser el número que obtuvo m
k más 15 el número que obtuvo tom son 15
unidades más 15 unidades más que el
número que obtuvo m que que fue 17
así es que el número que obtuvo tom es
17 15 y cuánto es 17 15 pues lo vamos a
hacer por aquí tenemos 17 que es una
decena y 7 unidades y le vamos a sumar
15 pero 15 es una decena y 5 unidades y
lo estamos sumando y bueno empecemos por
las unidades tenemos siete unidades más
cinco unidades y 7-5
son doce pero pues 12 es como 10 más 2 y
de hecho la podemos reagrupar así que
ponemos las dos unidades por aquí y
escribimos la decena por acá que bueno
también se puede decir como que
escribimos 2 y llevamos una nunca pero a
lo que nos referimos es que tenemos dos
unidades y una decena el 12 son dos
unidades y una decena y ahora ya nada
más nos falta sumar las decenas una
decena más una decena más una decena son
tres decenas y listo
tenemos 32 great obtuvo un 32 al girar
esta ruleta y siempre es una buena idea
checar si la respuesta es correcta
así es que veamos mk obtuvo el número 17
y tam obtuvo un número que tiene 15
unidades más que el de mk entonces
tenemos la respuesta correcta pues sí
porque m que obtuvo 17 y thom obtuvo un
número que es 15 unidades mayor que 17 y
17 más 15 es 32